9 sınıf 2 temaya devam ediyoruz bugün
iyonik bağdan bahsedeceğim çok önemli
bir kısımdır İyonik bağ şöyle güzel bir
şekilde detayl alım Öncelikle neyden
bahsedelim İyonik bağ nasıl oluşuyor
kimle kimin arasında oluşuyor Bu
detaylardan bahsedelim dostum Bak
müfredat değişti Eyvallah ta 12 sınıfa
kadar sürekli müfredatın değişecek yani
beraber daha çok işimiz var o yüzden
abone olarak izlersen beni takip edersen
çok mutlu olurum Böylelikle
gelişmelerden de haberdar olursun hadi o
zaman vakit kaybetmiyoruz hazırsan
başlayalım şimdi iyonik bağa geçmeden
önce şundan bahsetmemiz lazım bir atom
neden elektron vermek ister veya neden
elektron almak ister sebebi şudur
soygaza benzemeye çalışmak Çünkü soygaza
benzediğinden daha kararlı bir hale
gelecek bak şimdi burada gösteriyor işte
Soygazlar kararlı yapıdaki atomlardır
diyor diğer atomlar da elektron alarak
ya da elektron vererek soygaz
kararlılığına yani elektron
dizilimlerini soygaza benzetmeye
çalışırlar dostum Peki o zaman Soygazlar
nasıl bileşik yapar Evet Soygazlar
bileşik yapmaz diyoruz Çünkü kararlı
Yapı dadar bileşik yapmaya çok da
istekli değildirler çok istisnai
örnekleri vardır böyle zorlamayla
bileşik yaptırılan ama onlar şu an
konumuzun içerisinde değil dostum genel
olarak metaller elektron vererek
ametaller ise elektron alarak soygaza
benzemektedir Çünkü son katmanındaki o
değerlik elektron sayısını soygaza
benzetmeye çalışmak var ya işte onun
için mesela son katmanındaki değerlik
elektron sayısı fazla olanlar kimler
Bunlar ametaller genel olarak da 4A 5A
6a 7A grup grubundaki elementlerden
bahsediyoruz Bunlar elektron alarak daha
böyle daha kolaydır elektron alarak
soygaza benzemeye çalışırlar metaller
ise 1A 2A 3A grubundakiler bahsediyorum
Bunlar da elektron vererek soygaza
benzemeye çalışırlar ha ametallerin
elektronları ortak kullanarak da soygaza
benzeme durumu vardır O da zaten
kovalent bağ olarak daha sonra işlenecek
dostum İşte bu elektron alışverişi
sonucunda metalle ametal arasında
bileşik oluşmaktadır Biz bunlara iyonik
bağlı bileşikler Diyoruz ki önce şu
Metal metallerden bahsedelim metaller
başka bir atom ile bileşik oluştururken
her zaman elektron verme isteğinde
dirler kimden bahsediyoruz 1A 2A ve 3A
grubundaki metallerden bahsedebiliriz
işte 1A ve 2A grubundaki metallerin
valans elektronları yani değerlik
elektron sayıları azdır değil mi 1 A'nın
1'dir 2 a'nın 2'dir yani 1A grubundaki
element bir elektron verdiğinde kendini
ne yapar soygaza benzetir şöyle
söyleyeyim dostum mesela sodyumdan
bahsedeyim sodyum 11 nasıl yazılır 1 S2
2 S2 2p 6 3S 1'dir değil mi şimdi bundan
bir önceki soygaz şu değil mi neon neon
10 1 S2 2 S2 2p 6 işte sodyum ne yapmak
ister soygaza benzemek ister işte Şu son
katmanındaki bir elektronu vererek ne
yapar bir elektron verdiğinde sodyum
artık + 1 yüklü hale gelmiş olur Çünkü 1
elektron verdi 10 elektronu var 11
protonu var işte elektron dizilimini
kime benzetmiş oldu neona benzetmiş oldu
soygaza benzemiş oldu işte metaller
değerlik elektronlarını vererek soygaza
benzerler burada da bak hangi örneği
göstermiş lityumu vermiş mesela lityum
ne yapar şu bir elektronu verdiğinde
helyuma benzer değil mi Çünkü helyumun
elektron dizilimi şuydu 1 S2 di işte
lityum bir elektron verdi helyuma
benzedi ve bu şekilde ne yaptı kararlı
hale geldi lityum bir elektron verdiğin
için de lityum + 1 yüklü oldu buradaki
artı + 1 anlamına gelmektedir mesela
magnezyum elektron dizilimi 1 S2 2 S2 2
P6 3 s2d şu ik elektronu verdiğinde 8A
soygazın benzeyecek Ee o zaman 2
elektron verirse Magnezyum hangi hale
gelmiş olacak + 2 yüklü hale gelmiş
olacak ve elektron dizilimini de kime
benzetmiş oldu neon soygazın benzetmiş
oldu 1 S2 2 S2 2p 6 olan duruma benzetti
işte şöyle bir şey vardır metaller için
şunu söyleyebilirsin metaller elektron
vererek ne yapar kararlı hale gelir
soygaza benzer ve düşün aynı periyottaki
benzemiyor bir üsttekine benziyor Bak
şöyle göstereceğim periyodik tabloyu şu
şekilde çizmek istiyorum basit bir
şekilde 1A 2A Bir de 3A olduğu durumu
çizeyim şöyle göstereyim Bu da diğer
taraf şöyle değil mi aynı hizada yaptık
İnşallah dur şöyle göstereyim hı şöyle
çizdik Tamam şunlar Soygazlar 8A grubu
şu taraf değil mi 8A grubu şöyle şurası
3 periyot 2ci periyot diye gidiyor şöyle
çizersem Eğer Heh şimdi dikkat et bak
sodyum şurada sodyum burada magnezyum da
burada sodyum bir elektron verdi kime
benzedi Bir önceki periyottaki yani
ikinci periyottaki soygaza benzedi veya
Şuradaki lityum bahsetsem Onun da şöyle
rengini lityumu şu renkle göstereyim
lityum bir elektron verdi Bir önceki
periyottaki helyuma benzedi yani
metaller elektron vererek soygaza
benzediğinden periyodundaki benzemez Bir
önceki periyottaki benzer tamam mı
dostum Bak önemli bir ayrıntıdır
ametaller ise genel olarak elektron
olarak ne yapar işte şeye benzerler
soygaza benzerler ama ametallerin başka
bir ametalle elektron ortaklaşması
yaparak da bileşik oluşturma veya
molekül oluşturma durumu vardır ama biz
şu an iyonikler bahsettiğimiz için E ne
yapacak metal elektron verdi O
elektronlar boşta mı duracak sanıyorsun
Hayır ametal böyle yapıyor Aha boşta
elektron diyor hop alıyor onları ve
soygaza benziyor Mesela şöyle Flora
örnek gösterelim florun elektron
dizilimini vermiş 1 S2 2 S2 2p 5 demiş
Peki neon neydi neon 1 S2 2 S2 2p 6'yı
değil mi şimdi şöyle bir şey soracağım
Bu flor şu 7 elektronu vererek mi
soygaza Kolay benzeyebilir yoksa
dışarıdan bir tane alarak mı
elektronlarını soygaza benzetebilir E
tabii ki bir elektron alarak değil mi ya
atomlar da kolaylığı tercih eder O
yüzden işte değerlik elektron sayısı
büyük olanlar elektron alarak soygaza
benzemeye çalışırlar ki bu da neona
benziyor işte burada bunu söylüyor flor
dışarıdan bir elektron aldı ve ne yaptı
işte 88'e tamamladı yani soygaza
benzemiş oldu mesela kükürt atomu var 1
S2 2 S2 2 P6 3 S2 3 p4 mesela argonu
yazayım Argon 18 1 S2 2 S2 2 P6 3 S2 3p
6'dır o zaman dışarıdan buna 2 elektron
ilave ettiğimde ne yapacak işte 8'e
tamamlamış olacak 6 aydı ya 8'e
tamamlamak için ne yapması lazım
dışarıdan iki elektron alması lazım işte
ametallerde iyonik bağlı bileşik
oluştururken elektron alma isteği daha
fazladır diyoruz o yüzden de eksi yüklü
iyon oluştururlar ve şöyle bir şey
vardır artı yüklü iyonun ismi neydi kat
yondu şu artıdan anla artı yüklü iyonlar
sodyum + 1 magnezyum + 2 alüminyum + 3
gibi örnekler verebiliriz Bir de ne
vardı anyonlar Vardı hocam sanki eksik
yazdın orayı doğru Eksik yazdım
anyonlarda eksi yüklüydü onu da şuradan
anlaman için yaptım Bunu Mesela işte
flor -1 kükür -2 azot -3 gibi örnekler
verebilirim dostum ve şöyle bir şey
vardır dublet kararlılığı veya oktet
kararlılığı diye bir şey vardır bir
atomun elektron dizilimini helyuma
benzetmesine dublet kararlılığı diğer
soygazlara benzetmesine ise oktet
kararlılığı diyoruz dostum mesela mesela
Mesela şöyle örnek vereyim kim olsun
lityum bahsedelim lityum 3'tür değil mi
1 S2 2 S1 bu kararlı olmak için ne yapar
bir elektronu verir değil mi 7 7 tane
elektron alıp da o katmandaki soygaza
benzemeye çalışmayacak değil mi Bir tane
elektronu verdiğinde + 1 yüklü hale
geldi bak 1 S2 oldu işte ne yaptı
helyuma benzedi değil mi helyuma
benzediği için bu hangi kararlılığa
ulaşmış oldu dublet kararlılığına
ulaşmış oldu kötü yazdım Tabii ki
kararlılığı Tamam mesela mesela başka
bir örnek oksijen diyelim oksijen 8 1 S2
2 S2 2p 4 soygaza benzemek için P6
yapmaya çalışacak ya diğer Soygazlar P6
ile bitiyordu 2 elektron alsa süper
olmaz mı oksijen ne yapar dışarıdan 2
elektron aldı 1 S2 2 S2 2 P6 Bak diğer
soygazlardan birine benzemiş oldu buna
da oktet kararlılığı diyoruz dostum
şöyle bir şey helyuma benzemek yani S2
ile 1 S2 ile bitecek şekilde olmak
dublet P6 ile bitenlerde neymiş oktet
kararlılığıyla diyor ki 3 periyottaki
alkali metalin yani 1A grubu
elementinden bahsediyor elektron
dizilimi kararlı bileşiklerinde ikinci
periyottaki soygaza Benzer diyor 3
periyottaki alkali metal 1 S2 2 S2 2 P6
1A grubu olduğu için S1 ile bitmeli 3
periyot dediği için 3 S1 şimdi Bu ne
yapar bileşik oluştururken kararlı hale
gelmek için şu bir elektron undan
kurtulur ve neye dönüşür 1 S2 2 S2 2 P6
Evet ikinci periyot soygazın benzer
doğru bir ifadedir diyor ki halojenlerin
Halojen dediğimiz neydi 7A grubuyuz -1
yüklü anyonları oktet kararlılığında
diyor bir tane hemen Halojen yazalım 1
S2 2 S2 2p 5'i kararlı olmak için ne
yapar dışarıdan bir elektron alır ve
flor neye dönüşür -1 dönüşür 1 S2 2 S2
2p 6 oldu Evet P6 ile bitenler oktet
kararlılığıyla kı yapıya ulaşırlar
demiştim ya ametaller elektron olarak
Evet kararlı yapıya ulaşırlar ama
ortaklaşa kullandıkları durumlar da
vardı o yüzden her zaman ifadesinden
dolayı bu yanlıştır cevabım 1 ve 2
olacaktır Yani b seçeneği şu soruya
bakalım Diyor ki alüminyum atomu ile
ilgili alüminyum 13 1 S2 2 S2 2p 6 3 S2
3 P1 H Şimdi ben 5 tane elektron alıp P6
mı benzesem daha kolay yoksa şu 3 tane
elektronu ver hemen soygaza benzemek mi
daha kolay işte bak dostum unutma 1A 2A
3A ne yapar elektron vererek vererek
soygaza benzemeye çalışırlar Ve bir
önceki periyottaki soygaza benzerler O
zaman bu elektron vermeye yatkındır
metal olduğu için doğru + 3 yüklü iyonu
bak şu 3 elektronu verirse ne kalacak
geriye alüminyum + 3 kalacak 3 elektron
verdiği için 3 elektron verince 13'tür
ya nötr halde 13 protonu 13 elektronu
vardı e 3 elektronu verince ne oldu 10
elektronu kaldı e yükle elektron
sayısını topladığımızda Proton sayısını
verdiği için + 3 yüklü bu e 10 olduğuna
göre 1 S2 2 S2 2 P6 oldu elektron
dizilimi Evet ne oldu P6 ile bittiği
için oktet kararlılığında doğru diyor ki
5 elektron aldığında oktet kararlılığına
ulaşır Bir dakika şimdi çok mantıklı
geliyor değil mi şuraya 5 tane elektron
alırız P6 dönüşür O oktet kararlılığı
çok güzel ama alüminyum metalinden
bahsediyoruz metal elektron almaz
elektron verir o yüzden O yüzden bu
ifade yanlıştır He 2nin doğru olduğunu
söylemiştik değil mi Çok güzel E biz
yanlışı aradığımız için cevabımız yalnız
3 C seçeneği şimdi iyonik bağın
oluşumundan bahsedelim dedik ya bir
metal elektron vermek isteyecek ametal
is o verilen elektronu alacak o zaman
metal elektron verdiğinde katyona
dönüşecek metalde elektronu aldığında
anyona dönüşecek biri artı yüklü biri
eksi yüklü artı ve eksi ne yapar
birbirine elektrostatik çekim güçleriyle
çeker işte ne oluyor birinin elektron
verip diğerinin o elektronu alması
sonucunda oluş iyonların anyon ve
katyonun birbirini çekmesi sonucunda
oluşan yapıya Biz ne diyormuş İyonik bağ
diyormuş dostum burada da bunu Açıklıyor
işte bir katyon ile anyon arasında
elektron alışverişi sonucunda aslında
bir metalle bir ametal arasında elektron
alışverişi genellikle böyle ifade edilir
alışverişi sonucunda meydana gelen anyon
ve katyonun elektrostatik çekim
güçleriyle birbirini çekmesi sonucunda
ne oluşuyor İyonik bağ oluşuyor diyoruz
dostum iyonik bağın oluşması için ne
gerekiyormuş o zaman elektron alışverişi
gerekiyormuş Ve önemli bir ayrıntı var
Mesela şöyle söyleyeyim magnezyum ile
şöyle magnezyum 12 ile kim arasında
olsun azot 7 arasında bileşik yapmaya
çalışıyorum diyelim magnezyumu yazalım 1
S2 2 S2 2 P6 3 S2 şimdi bu kararlı olmak
için ne yapar 2 elektron verir değil mi
magnezyum + 2'ye dönüşür Bunlar gitti
bak 2 elektron verdi 2 elektron verir
diye yazıyorum şuraya şunu yazalım 1 S2
2 S2 2p 3 ha p 6'ya tamamlamak daha
kolay o zaman bu ne yapacak 3 elektron
alır diyoruz Bu da azot - 3'e dönüştü
değil mi şimdi bak alınan verilen
elektron sayısı iyonik bağlı
bileşiklerde eşit olmak zorunda E o
zaman bu 2 elektron veriyorsa bak 2
elektron veriliyor veriliyor 3 elektron
alınıyor bunları nasıl eşitlensin burayı
3 ile çarparsın Burayı da 2 ile
çarparsın olur sana toplamda altışar
elektron magnezyum toplamda 3 tane
olursa 6 Elektron vermiş olacak azot da
2 tane olduğunda Toplamda 6 elektron
almış olacak Böylelikle bileşiğin
formülü de çıkmış oluyor aslında
magnezyumdan 3 tane azottan da 2 tane
oluyor Al sana bileşiğin formülü böyle
bir yöntemle de yapabilirsin ya da
yükler var ya + 2 -3 artı ve eksinin
önemi yok Burada 2 ile 3'ü çapraz la Al
sana bileşiğin formülü onu zaten Daha
sonra detayl acağı gel şimdi şuraya
bakalım nötr sodyum atomu neydi 1 S2 2
S2 2 P6 3 S1 de şu bir elektronu vererek
ne yapacaktır soygaz kararlılığına
ulaşacaktır çok güzel Korsa 1 S2 2 S2 2
P6 3 S2 3p 5'i dışarıdan bir elektron
olacak bu verdi bu da aldı E bu da ne
oldu işte bak zaten bunun verdiği
elektronu almış oldu aslında böylelikle
bu da P6 ya geldi Bak bu da -1 oldu işte
Peki daha önce görmüştük Biz ne
görmüştük bir element elektron
verdiğinde çapı ne oluyordu küçülüyordu
elektron aldığında ne oluyordu çapı
artıyordu o zaman o zaman sodyum klora
bir tane elektron verdiği için sodyumun
çapı gördün mü küçüldü sodyum + 1'in
çapı daha küçük oluyor klorun çapı İsa
Ne oldu arttı burada Aslında çok
aynıymış gibi duruyor ama birazcık daha
büyüktür aslında Hatta ben şöyle bir şey
yapmak istiyorum Bak dur şöyle
göstereyim kopyala yapıştır biraz şöyle
büyüterek koyacağım buraya Heh şöyle
daha mantıklı olur böyle Mesela şöyle
bir soru verebilir sana getirdi şöyle
bir tane yuvarlak koyayım şuraya Dedim
ki buna x ne olsun x ya x demeyelim ya
aman ne uğraşıyorum magnezyum Ya yok
kalsiyum kalsiyum 20 dedi kalsiyum 20
atomu dedi Hatta bunu birazcık da şöyle
büyük yapmak istiyorum şöyle büyüt
sallıyorum şu anda bak tamamen
sallıyorum çapını Mesela ben bunun
çapına Ne diyeyim uyduralım Bir şey
değil mi mesela mesela mesela dedim ki
185 ya da 215 pikometre dedim salladım
renkler hep karışacak la burada Neyse
sıkıntı yok şimdi diğer diğer atomdan
bahsedelim mesela mesela kloru koyalım
klorda şöyle CL2 var yapısı Hatta şundan
kopyalayarak koyalım bir dakika şundan
aldık çoğalttık Heh Bu da şöyle CL2 CL
ve CL atomları buradaki C llerin her
birinin çapının mesela 181 pikometre
olduğunu söyledim 181 pikometre dedi ki
bunların arasında iyonik bağlı bir
bileşik oluşuyormuş iyonik bağlı bileşik
oluştuğunda şöyle bir şey oluyormuş Bak
şunu çoğalttım aldım şu biraz küçülmüş
sonra şunu aldım koydum bu da biraz
büyümüş halde böyle bir yapı meydana
geldiğini söylüyor mesela bu Tabii
şematik gösterim gerçeği böyle değil
tabii ki ve şunu söylüyor şuna kalsiyum
+ 2 diyor Şuna da veya Hatta şuraya
kalsiyum M + diyor Şuna da CL - n diyor
ya da n ek diyor şöyle yazıyor Mesela
şuna kaç yazsın Hatta 181 şimdi Biraz
şey oldu Tabii ki değerler saçma oldu da
neyse uyduracak artık
235 pikometre dedim mesela 235 pikometre
gerçek değerler değil bunlar Bu arada
Şuna da mesela küçüldü küçüldü 110
pikometre dedim mesela salladık burada
Mesela neleri söyleyebilir bir der ki
kalsiyum elektron vermiştir Doğru mu
Doğru Çünkü
kalsiyumdan kalsiyum kaç elektron verdi
yani buradaki M sayısı kaçtır şunu
söyleyebilirsin dostum Bak bir tane
kalsiyumla kaç tane klor birleşmiş iki
tane klor birleşmiş O zaman şunu
söyleyebilirsin kalsiyum Demek ki 2
Elektron vermiş Korsa 1 elektron almış
eksi demek ek1 demek ha bunların
arasında oluşan bileşiğin formülü nedir
diye sorarsa Bak kalsiyumdan bir tane
var klordan ik tane var C CL 2 bu
yorumları İşte bu şekiller üzerinden ne
Yapabilirsin Yapabilirsin dostum burada
Bak o sodyum klorür bileşiği in
oluşumundan bahsediyor ya ne olmuştu
sodyum bir elektron verdi sodyum + 1'e
dönüştü Klor sa o bir elektronu aldı
Klor -1 dönüştü Böylelikle işte nacl
bileşiği oluşmuş oldu ama bunun oluşum
süreci nasıl oldu işte ne olacaktır önce
sodyum elementi ve Klor gazı arasında
tepkime Oldukça hızlı gerçekleşiyor bunu
bilmek lazım Hatta bu tepkimede böyle
parlak sarımsı yeşilimsi bir renk
meydana gelmekte sarı şeyden
kaynaklanıyor sodyumdan kaynaklanan bir
renk ve yüksek ısı açığa çıkıyor önce
sodyum katısı önce sonra gaza dönüşüyor
gaz haline dönüşmeden o elektron
kopamayız Bunu unutma dostum sodyum gaza
kadar geldi Eyvallah atomlar birbirinden
ayrıldı Normalde sodyumda böyle bir sürü
sodyum atomu bir arada bulunuyordu
Bunlar birbirinden ayrıldı ve sodyum
Daha sonra bir elektron vererek sodyum +
1 iyonuna dönüştü gaz halinde sonra Klor
gaz molekülü vardı ya burada işte Klor
atomlarına ayrıştı atomlarına ayrıştıran
sonra da buradan gelen elektronu kim
aldı Klor almaya başladı e sodyum + 1 ve
Klor -1 iyonları var değil mi bunlar ne
yaptı işte gaz halleri geldi
birbirlerine sodyum + 1 ve Klor -1 iyonu
tak birbirlerine tutundu Ondan sonra
tepkime gerçekleşti tekrar katıya
dönüştüler o enerji alışverişinden Sonra
işte sodyum sodyum + 1'e dönüşürken ne
yapıyor çapı küçülüyor Klor -1
dönüşürken Klor atomunun çapı büyüyor
Değil mi E oluşan bu iyonlar zıt yüklü
oldukları için birbirlerini çekiyor Ve
işte katı haldeki sodyum klorür
bileşiğini meydana Getiriyorlar ve
düzenli bir yapı meydana geliyor ki
orası çok önemlidir önce şunu söyleyelim
bunları dikkate alırsak zıt yüklü
iyonlar arasında meydana gelen güçlü
etkileşime Biz ne diyoruz İyonik bağ
diyoruz bu önemli bir ayrıntıdır ve
iyonik bağın meydana gelmesi için haline
ne olması lazım tanecikler arasında
elektron alışverişi olması lazım bir
elektron veriyor diğeri elektronu alıyor
Böylelikle iyonik bağlanma meydana
gelmiş oluyor işte Bak burada sodyum ne
yaptı elektron verdi O elektronları Klor
aldı ve böylelikle sodyum + 1 ve Klor -1
iyonu oluştu ve şöyle bir yapı meydana
getirdi hepsi bir arada bulunuyor ha
hocam o zaman Zan benim sodyum klorür
dediğimde sadece sodyum klorür
molekülleri yok mu yok dostum Bak nacl
molekülü yoktur Hocam niye yoktur Çünkü
bu artı ve eksiler arasında çekim
meydana gelir Onun da görüntüsünü hemen
göstermem lazım Aha burada işte böyle
bir yapı meydana geliyor yani sodyum
Klor sodyum Klor Bak görüyor musun Şu
sodyum + 1 iyonu şu da Klor ek1 iyonu
bir sürü sodyum bir sürü klora
bağlanmaktadır ki bak detayını şurada
göstereyim sana bak şu kloru görüyor
musun Şu klora bir tane sodyum Buradan
bir tane sodyum Buradan bir tane Buradan
bir tane Buradan bir tane Aşağıdan bir
tane yukarıdan bak 6 tane bağlanıyor e
aynı şey sodyum için de geçerli mesela
hangi sodyumdan bahsedeyim şu kenardaki
sodyumdan bahsedeyim bak şu kenardaki
sodyuma bir Klor Buradan bir tane
Buradan bir tane Buradan bir tane
arkadan bir tane bu taraftan bir de
görmediğimiz bu yönden geliyor Yani 6
sodyumla 6 Klor aslında bir yapı meydana
getiriyor biz sadeleşmiş haline
baktığımız için biz buna
ncl birim hücresi diyoruz birim hücre
yani iyonik bağlı bileşiklerde molekül
yoktur Ne varmış birim hücre varmış
dostum önemli bir ayrıntıdır iyonik
bağlı molekül yoktur molekül kovalent
bağlılarda vardır tamam mı dostum
serbest molekül yok birim hücreler
vardır iyonik bağlı bileşiklerde Bunu
sakın unutma dostum y bir iki örnek daha
yapalım mesela magnezyumla Klor arasında
oluşan bileşikten bahsedecek ne yapacak
bu ik elektronu verecek magnezyum + 2'ye
dönüştü şimdi magnezyum + 2 çok güzel
Klor da -1 doğru mu şimdi Klor bir
elektron alabiliyor bu ise 2 elektron
verebiliyor o zaman alınan verilen
elektron sayısını eşitlemek için aşağıyı
ne yapmam lazım benim 2 ile çarpmamı
yani bir tane magnezyum ik tane klorla
birleşmek He çok güzel işte yapısı
burada gözüktüğü gibi oluyor ne olacak
işte Klor valans elektron sayısı 7'di
bir tane elektron aldı soygaza benzedi
magnezyum valans elektron sayısı 2'ydi o
ik elektronu verdi soygaza benzedi ve
sonuçta magnezyum ortada + 2 klorla da
sağında solunda olacak şekilde böyle bir
yapı meydana geldi hocam yukarısında
aşağısında olamaz mı ya olabilir ya Ben
gösterim olarak böyle yaptım tamam mı
dostum mesela Heh magnezyumla azot
Aslında bunu yapmıştım ne yapar
magnezyum 2 elektron verir bak bu 2
elektron verdi verir E bu şey ne yapacak
Azot ne yapacak azot da dışarıdan 3
elektron alacak e alınan verilen
elektron sayısını eşitlemek için Şurayı
3 ile çarpmamı şurayı da 2 ile çarpmamı
Demek ki 3 tane magnezyum ik tane azotla
birleşerek bileşik oluşturacak bunu
Hatta şöyle yazabilirim 3 magnezyum + 2
2 tane azot -3 şeklinde gösterebilirim
dostum demin söylediğim ifade işte
iyonik bağlı bileşiklerin örgü
yapısından bahsediyoruz Yani tek başına
bir tane sodyumla bir tane klor
bulunmuyor bir sürü bulunuyor şöyle üç
boyutlu bir yapı vardır normalde evdeki
tuzlara da bakarsan tuz kristallerinde
böyle bir yapıyı böyle mikros altında
gözlemleyebilirsiniz
bağlı bileşikler yapısal olarak birim
hücr hücrelidir diyor e ve bu birim
hücreler işte Farklı farklıdır yani
sodyum klorürün böyle ama diğer
atomların K Daha doğrusu diğer
bileşikleri böyle olmak zorunda değil
Birazdan göstereceğim zaten onu zıt
yüklü iyonların
çekim kuvvetleriyle oluşturduğu bu
düzenli yapıya iyonik kristal örgü
Diyoruz ki iyonik bağlı bileşikler O
yüzden iyonik kristal olarak iyonik katı
olarak ifade edilmekte Heh işte sodyum
klorürün yapısı bu ne oluyor işte kübik
bir yapıdan bahsediyoruz burada başka
bileşikler de var Mesela bu ne kalsiyum
Sülfür kalsiyum sülfürün yapısı bu
mesela sezyum florürün mesela Buna da
benziyor başka kalsiyum flor ünkü Bak bu
şekildeyken örgüleri birbirinden
farklıdır ama sonuçta iyonik bağlı
bileşikler birim hücre yapılıdır molekül
yapılı değildir tamam mı dostum Bunu yaz
bir kenara karşında Dursun şimdi iyonik
bağlı bileşiklerin şöyle özelliklerinden
de bahsedelim neydi Bak burada bir sürü
tuz var aslında tuzlar genellikle neydi
işte iyonik bağlı bileşikler olarak
ifade ediyorduk genel olarak
söylediğimiz ifade şudur bak metal ile
ametalin birleşmesi sonucunda oluşan
bileşiklerde Ama şöyle bir örneği de
vardır aslında Doğru ifadenin şöyle
olması gerekiyor katon ile anyonun
elektrostatik çekimlerle birleşmesi
sonucunda oluşur mesela nh4 + iyonu ile
mesela Klor eksi iyonu Bu da iyonik
bağlıdır Ama hocam azotta hidrojende
ametal biri 7A şey pardon ne 7 a'sı 5A
birisi de 1A grubundaki hidrojen e
Bunlar da ametal Bunlar da ametal hocam
burada metal yok işte Evet bak nh4 olan
bir katyon var bu katyonun olduğu iyonik
bağlı bileşikler de mevcuttur yani Bunu
da istisnai olarak bir kenarda aklında
tut evet genel olarak Metal ametal
iyonik bağlı bileşik yapar ama böyle nh4
gibi katyonlar da vardır anyon la
katyonun iyonik bağlı bileşik yaptığını
bilsen daha güzel olur dostum Heh
bakalım Özellikleri neymiş kristal
örgüde yük denkliği vardır yani alınan
elektron sayısı Neyse verilen elektron
sayısı da aynı olmak zorunda veya işte
demin yazdığım örnek magnezyum + 2'ydi
azot -3'ten buradaki yük denkliği yani
eksi ile artının sayısının eşitlenmesi
için bunu 3 ile bunu 2 ile çarparsın + 6
-6 olur o yüzden magnezyum nitrür bu
şekilde gözükür 3 magnezyum 2 azot
şeklinde Heh iyonik bağlı bileşikler
nötr yapılıdır bunu bilmek gerekiyor Bak
bu önemli bir ifade katyon sayısı anyon
sayısına eşit olmayabilir Bak burada
görüyor musun 3 tane katyon var İki tane
anyon var ha sodyum klorür de bir katyon
bir anyon var eşit veya işte Kalsiyum
klorür de 2 anyon bir katyon var yani
anyon katyon sayısı her zaman eşit olmak
zorunda değil dostum ve iyonik bağlı
bileşikler oda koşullarında katı halde
bulunur Bu çok önemli bir şeydir yüksek
erime ve kaynama noktalarına sahiptirler
Uçucu olmayan katılardır yani Oda
şartlarında bıraktığında öyle uçup
gitmezler erime ve kaynama noktaları
yüksektir katı halde elektriği
iletmezler ama sulu çözeltileri ve sıvı
hali elektriği iletir Çünkü sulu
çözeltiye girdiğinde o kristal örgüsü
suya dağılır ortamda artı ve eksi yüklü
iyonlar olduğu için iyonlar üzerinden
elektrik akımı iletilebilir aynı şekilde
sıvı halde de kristal örgü bozuluyor
ortamda artı ve eksi yüklü iyonlar
bulunuyor Bunlar üzerinden elektrik
akımı iletilebilir O zaman şunu
söylüyoruz katı halde elektriği
iletmezler sıvı ve sulu çözelti halinde
elektriği iletirler diyoruz ve iyonik
bağlı bileşiklerin formülleri en
sadeleşmiş şekliyle yazılır onu da hemen
örneklendirmek istiyorum mesela diyelim
Kurşun + 4 iyonu oluşturdu mesela mesela
mesela ne olsun kükürt de -2 iyonu
oluşturdu Şimdi burada alınan verilen
elektron sayısını eşitlemek için yani
yükleri eşitlemek için burayı 1 le
Burayı da 2 ile çarparsın değil mi yani
buna pb S2 bileşiği dersin gidip de şunu
demezsin pb2 S4 sadeleşiyor bu sayılar
sadeleşir ve bu hale gelir Yani en
sadeleşmiş haliyle yazılmaktadır mesela
demin dedim ya 6 tane sodyum 6 tane
klorla birleşiyor Ama işte bunlar
yazılmadığı için nacl şeklinde
gösteriliyor demiştim Burada da onu
söylüyor işte ne yapıyor iyonik bağlı
bileşiklerde en basit oran yazılmaktadır
diyoruz ve moleküler yapılı değildirler
neydi birim hücre yapılıdır bu önemli
ifadeyi Bak burada bir daha söylemiş
olduk sert ve kırılgandır yani
vurduğunda dağılır tuz böyle şeyler
vardır tuz madenlerinden tuz kristalleri
çıkarılır öğütür değil mi yani
vurduğumuzda kırılabilen bir yapıya
sahiptirler ve şu vardır içerdikleri tüm
Bağlar güçlü etkileşimlerdir yani İyonik
bağ güçlü etkileşimdir iyonik bağlı
bileşiklerde de güçlü etkileşimler
bulunmaktadır Bundan dolayı da sadece ve
sadece kimyasal yöntemlerle
elementlerine yani bileşenlerine
ayırabilirsin fiziksel yöntemlerle
ayıramazsın şimdi gel bakalım buradaki
sorularda ne diyor alüminyum metali ile
Klor ametali arasında oluşan iyonik
bağlı bileşikte bir tane alüminyum atomu
3 farklı Klor atomuna elektron verir
diyor şimdi yazacağız bunu alüminyum 13
1 S2 2 S2 2p 6 3 S2 3 P1 3A grubudur e
bileşik oluştururken ne yapmak ister
soygaza benzemek için 3 elektron verir
değil mi yani şu hale geldi Çok güzel e
Klor ne yapacaktır 17 1 S2 2 S2 2p 6 3
S2 3p 5 bu 3 elektron verdi bak ne
yapacaktır bu 3 elektron verir bu ise 1
elektron alır alınan verilen elektron
sayısını eşitlem gerekiyorsa aşağıyı ne
ile çarpmamı 3le çarpmamı yani bir tane
alüminyum 3 tane klora elektron
verecektir doğru bir ifadedir bunu D
diye yazdık diyor ki katyon ve anyon
arasında oluşan katyon anyon arasında
oluşan elektrostatik çekim kuvveti bu
iyonik bağın tanımıyo bir ifadedir diyor
ki iyonik katılar el Elektrik akımını
iletmez ancak sulu çözeltileri ve sıvı
hali elektriği iletir söylemiştik doğru
bir ifadedir iyonik kristalde bir iyonik
kristalde bir katyon sadece bir anyon
tarafından çekime maruz kalır bak
bakayım bir katon işte alüminyum + 3 ama
3 tane klor -1 iyonu var demek ki her
zaman böyle bir durum söz konusu değil
değişebilir Bunun da ne oldu yanlış
olduğunu bulduk iki farklı element
arasında oluşan Bir bileşiğin bağın
iyonik bağı olup olmadığı elementlerin
iyonlaşma Enerjileri arasındaki farka ve
elektronegatiflikleri farkına bağlıdır
Evet şöyle bir şey vardır
elektronegatiflik farkı arttıkça İyonik
bağ karakteri artmaktadır bu doğru bir
ifadedir diyor ki kalsiyum ve fosfor
elementleri arasında oluşan iyonik
kristalde katyon böl anyon oranı 3/2
dirir Hemen yazalım kalsiyum 20 1 S2 2
S2 2p 6 3 S2 3p 6 4 S2 bu 2 elektron
vererek kalsiyum + 2'ye dönüşmek ister
Yani 2 elektron verdi şöyle V yazım
yazdım neydi diğeri de fosfor fosfor 15
yazalım 1 S2 2 S2 2p 6 3 S2 3p 3 5A
grubu dışarıdan 3 elektron alarak ne
yapar soygaza benzeyebilir o zaman
alınan verilen elektron sayısının
eşitlenmesi için burayı 3le burayı da 2
ile çarpalım 6 da eşitlem olalım yani
kalsiyumdan diğer bir ifadeyle kondan 3
tane fosfordan fosf ya da bundan da 2
tane alırsak tamamlamış oluyoruz o zaman
tyon bölü anyon oranını sorduğu için 3/2
oranını elde ederiz yani bu ifade Ne
oldu doğru oldu dostum diyor ki tüm
iyonik kristallerin örgü yapısı aynıdır
farklı olduğunu göstermiştim farkı biri
kübik oluyor biri böyle değişik değişik
oluyor şekil şekildir aynı olmak zorunda
değildir bir iyonik kristalde itme
Kuvvetleri en az çekme Kuvvetleri de en
çok olacak şekilde kristal örgüsü oluşur
Evet çünkü iyonik bağlı bileşiklerde
çekme Kuvvetleri çok fazladır itmeyi
minimum yapacak şek şekilde zaten o
İyonik bağ örgüsü oluşmaktadır doğru bir
ifadedir iyonik bağlı bileşikler birim
hücreden oluşur moleküler yapılı
değildir Doğru bir ifadedir diyor ki
buradaki soruda oda koşullarında
Aşağıdaki maddelerden hangisi zıt yüklü
tanecikler arasında oluşan kristal örgü
yapısına sahip değildir zıt yüklü
iyonlar arasında kristal örgü yani
iyonik bağlı bileşik değildir diye
soruyor iyonik bağlı bileşikler neydi
metall metal arasında oluyordu Şu
verilenleri yazıyorum Bak hidrojen 1 1
S1 1A grubunda Ama bu neydi amaldi onun
yanına yazdık lityum var lityum 3 1 S2 2
S1 1A
grubundayım da sığdır alım biraz küçülte
başka ne var oksijen var 8 1 S2 2 S2 2p
4'tür 6a grubu Bu da metaldir onu da
yazdık bak başka ne var sodyum var şu
tarafa yazmak istiyorum 11 1 S2 2 S2 2
P6 3 S1 1A grubu metaldir onun altına
magnezyum var magnezyum 12 1 S2 2 S2 2
P6 3 S2 2A grubu Bu da metal Başka kim
var Klor var 17 1 S2 2 S2 2p 6 3 S2 3p 5
7A grubu Neydi bu TDi ve brom var
brom 35 1 S2 2 S2 2p 6 3 S2 3 P6 4 S2 3
d10 4 P5 P5 ile bittiği için 7A grubu Bu
da ametal deir çok güzel O zaman şöyle
yazayım ametal işte başka şu ametalleri
belirtelim ametal ametal a flor da
varmış orada tamam flor da zaten P5 de
bitiyordu O da ametal zaten bu ne işte
metaller ametalleri belirtecek değil mi
ametal ametal çok güzel şunlar da
metaller imiz bak şunlar da bizim
metaller imiz o zaman Metal ametal
iyonik Metal ametal iyonik Metal ametal
iyonik Metal ametal iyonik tamamı ametal
C6 h12 o6 şeker molekülü bu molekül
halindedir kovalent bağlıdır o yüzden
cevap D seçeneğidir şimdi şu soruya
bakalım iyonik kristal vermiş bana çok
güzel diyor ki katı halde Elektrik
akımını iletmez iyonik kristal neydi
iyonik bileşikler katı halde elektriği
il etmezdi doğru suda çözündüğünde
kristal yapısında ne oluyordu bozulma
meydana geliyordu o yüzden Elektrik
akımını iletebilir hale geliyordu
Doğrudur sıvı hali anyon katyon içermez
ya içerir sadece kristal örgüsü
bozuluyor o tekrar eski haline
geldiğinde tekrar kristal örgü oluşuyor
ama ne yapıyor sıvı hale getirdiğimizde
o artı ve eksi yüklü iyonlar işte
kristal örgüyü bozuyor ama yine ortamda
artı ve eksi yani anyon ve katyon
bulunmakta O yüzden elektriği iletiyor
zaten o yüzden bu ifade yanlıştır Biz
doğruları aradığımız için cevabımız C
seçeneğidir Evet bu dersin burada sonuna
gelelim iyonik bağlı bileşiklerin
nelerinden bahsettik Bir Elde
edilmesinden bahsettik nasıl yapılıyor
metal metal arasında olduğundan elektron
alışverişi olduğundan bahsettik anyon ve
katyon arasında elektrostatik çekim
dedik Bak bu önemli bir ifadeyi birim
hücreden oluşur molekül yapılı değildir
demiştik önemli detaylardan bahsettik ve
iyonik bağlı bileşiklerinin
özelliklerini söyledik beni dinlediğin
için teşekkür ederim belki Bu sınavda
faydası olabilir o yüzden bunu da böyle
dikkatlice Dinlemeni tavsiye ediyorum o
zaman iki fosfor bir asit kimya Bu kadar
basit görüşmek üzere for